also ich glaube das ist wirklich so eine
app wie sollte man sich nicht
runterladen kann herzlich kommt sondern
wie leute ich wollte wieder am start für
euch nach einer langen pause denn ich
war im urlaub bin ich jetzt wieder da
für euch es sind 36 karten deutet man
denkt sich aber morgens aussieht das
duell geht aber leute viele von euch
haben sie eine ganz spezielle sache für
das neue video gewünscht und dem komme
ich natürlich gerne nach ihr habt euch
gewünscht hat sich ein video zur neuen
wahnsinn von rebecca ding machen und
zwar leute hat rebecca ring einfach
lassen wir uns das auf der zunge
zergehen ein testvideo von verfluchten
apps gemacht wobei sich dieses level
erreicht sie stellt jetzt ihren
zuschauern schon die besten verfluchten
apps vor ok schau mal rein
ich bin mir wirklich sorgen bevor ihr
auf deinen seine inhalte eingehen
gebt euch einfach das hätte ja es ist
wirklich die seht ihr das 36 grad in
köln alter habe ich lag gesoffen was ist
das denn 36 grad in köln ich bin gerade
aus dem urlaub zurückgekommen leute und
was macht ihr hier drückt mir ein video
in dem rebecca wegen versuchter apps
testet ok egal wir werden heute um punkt
3 uhr drei verfluchte herunterladen und
ausprobieren aber an sich leute kennen
wir das ganze prinzip schon also rating
machten immer immer natürlich diese drei
uhr nachts videos aber heute leute und
das ist auch der grund warum dieses
video anschauen können wir uns
praktische tipps dafür abholen welche
verfluchten apps wirklich die besten da
draußen auf dem markt sind kennt es
nicht auch im wacht morgens auf und
denke ich dicker welche verfluchte app
ist eigentlich die beste
wir haben es jetzt 3
2 uhr zunahmen und so ist die rede von
dieser hier
ok countdown ab 2,9 sterne aus 1445
bewertung rebecca bist du sicher dass
das die beste verfeinerte drei besten
verfluchten apps ist befinden konnte man
sich mal so beck wir als zuschauer wie
wir haben ja auch wir wollen ja auch
informiert werden wir wollen ja wissen
was ist die am besten verfluchte app
welche app wurde so richtig geil
verflucht da draußen nicht ja unterlagen
das muss man sich vor augen halten
angeblich soll sie nicht herunterladen
warum haben leute diese app entwickelt
natürlich damit sie nicht
heruntergeladen wird jeder app
entwickler möchte dass seine apps
möglichst selten heruntergeladen wird
exakt aber was ich mitbekommen habe
oh ja ich meine das ist auf jeden fall
ist also klar ich mein hobby ist es der
die leute wissen wir alle
ihr könnt euch ja ihr könnt euch eine
app runterladen sollte natürlich nicht
runterladen also der app entwickler hat
die app entwickelt damit ihr sie euch
nicht runter ladet ihr könnt ihn
gefallen damit tun wenn sie nicht rose
landwirt aber wir sind natürlich alle
dumm ladung trotzdem mutter und dann
zeigt einem das iphone anhand der daten
die in iphone erheben kann heißt
standort uhrzeit die restliche
lebenszeit an perfekt das ist technisch
das ist mir auf jeden fall technisch
möglich kein problem und diese exakt
voraus wie viel zeit ihr noch
klingt megacool ganz kurz ernsthaft
gesprochen ich würde es glaube ich ich
würde es wissen wollen
ich würde es für ihr wissen wollen wann
ich sterbe als ich meine das ist
natürlich alles haarsträubend der unfug
und man das glaubt man wenn man sechs
jahre alt ist vielleicht auch acht aber
ich würde es mir vor wie ich würde es
wissen wollen hätte ich die möglichkeit
wirklich wissen wollen bei ganz ehrlich
dann bin ich auch selbst wenn ich weiß
okay du stirbst in 60 jahren
die 580 bender 84 dann wohl nicht mehr
motorrad und fahre mit diesem motorrad
außer geisteskrank auf letzter rille
weil ich weiss ehrlich sterben nicht bis
zu dem naja ich hab sie wollte gar nicht
hatten dort drei jahre zu leben und noch
zehn sekunden daher eigentlich anfangen
leute stopp wir müssen uns wirklich vor
augen hat wenn wir uns dieses video
reinziehen
es gibt viele viele viele viele tausend
hunderttausende menschen in deutschland
die das hier sehen und die das glauben
dürfen wir nicht vergessen wir als
menschen mit gehirnzellen und einem
gewissen alter die auch nachdenken
können ist natürlich ein legales
kompletter schrott aber was meint ihr
warum 550.000 wollte das angeschaut
bei becky weil wirklich leute denken
dass diese apps funktionieren können
hängengeblieben kehrt besser leben kommt
dass unsere lizenzvereinbarungen welt
natürlich natürlich leute verfluchte
apps müssen sie auch an regeln halten
okay ganz klar lieber nutzer lieber
potenzieller nutzer
du wirst in wenigen augenblicken
verfahren wie viel lebenszeit die noch
bleibt und wann du stirbst wir können
dir sagen wann du stirbst wir sind eine
der besten verfügung
aber bitte bevor sein können akzeptiert
ist mord zu vereinbaren und so gelaufen
wäre
das ist dann wirklich für wirklich
scheiße gelaufen einfach nur noch ein
jahr 380 knapp unter 2 jahre wer als
geneigte zuschauer wird natürlich woran
es liegt höchstwahrscheinlich wird in
zwei jahren irgendwie verfluchte
spongebob bekommt die siebenmal der
siemens ag hat die sie aufgeschnitten
hat und dann schneidet diese dann halt
sie aufsucht und jobs jobs jobs ist
natürlich ein thema über das man keinen
spaß macht aber da wir alle wissen dass
es hier kompletter unsinn ist kann sich
darüber trotzdem an spaß machen das
krasse ist wie action becky muss
mitspielen
ich meine ich glaube becky ist gar nicht
so dumm leute wie todd ich glaube es
nicht um glaube dieses schlauri weiß
schon ganz genau was sie macht aber sie
muss natürlich mitspielen weil sie muss
ernsthaft so tun als würde sie diese app
testen und das wird sie angst einjagen
damit eben ihre sehr jungen
zuschauerschaft von kanal und sechs bis
zehn jahren sichern denkt
dies gesehen
habt ihr das gesehen leute habt ihr das
gesehen die iphone kamera hat angefangen
zu blinken
also wenn das nicht weiß dafür ist dass
dieser effekt ist dann weiß ich auch
nicht
das ist wirklich ein du bist gerade dem
dachte ich das war eigentlich unsere
arbeit in die kamera blickt das
kameralicht lenkerin ständig wurden zwei
jahren
[Musik]
also wer wirklich kommt er denn gewählt
das hat diese app ist dafür gemacht sie
hat irgend effektive zahl angezeigt in
einem fall eben unter zwei jahre ist
häufig für dich ist natürlich dann
natürlich als todeszeitpunkt noch mal
leid an der stelle was sonst passiert
ein lichtblick und ein geräusch kommt
[Musik]
bin ich enttäuscht das ist einer der top
3 verflucht maps auf dem markt versucht
allerdings nicht mehr tragen möchte auf
deine kamera zu greifen
nein auf gar keinen fall nein wir weiter
dahinter steckt ja nicht wer weiß wer
dahinter steckt ja da steckt ein
entwickler der will dass seine app nicht
runter geladen wird
ganz klarer fall effektiv oder wer
entwickelt einen der entwickelten
verfluchte apps leute sind das
verfluchte entwickler oder sind
entwickler die an sich danach jemanden
von außen dazu holen der die app
verflucht oder haben diese software
studio so festangestellten verfluchter
zu hause das ist die dass sie spannende
frage leute also ich glaube das ist
wirklich okay das ist die erste app gut
was macht die 291 bewertung 28 sterne
also jetzt so werdet ihr wohl ein
bisschen ungehalten okay wir wollen
könnt ihr die die besten verfluchten
apps gezeigt bekommen die besten ok
nichts und 28 sterne bullshit aus 91
bewertung
vielleicht seid ihr auch schon mal
darauf gestoßen bei tik tok
okay okay alles klar da geht es etwas
mit ihm zu tun
bei 3 fand am rande ich leute ich bin
wirklich letzte so krass am tik tok
suchten ich kann mich auf meinen titel
von der beschreibung verlinken es werden
bald klickt und es kommen versprochen
was sehen wir hier ja eine person die
ich weiß nicht wer sich hayden aber die
sieht bisschen drogenabhängig aus oder
aber warum ist es jetzt verflucht 6d ich
kann aus ich gehe davon aus dass die
extremisten schlimmen sind wenn heißt
ich so elfjährige auf tik tok irgendwo
hingehen das auf tik tok festhalten dann
gehe ich davon aus vor allem wer sich
danach noch gepostet haben das in extrem
krasse sachen widerfahren sind die
schlimmsten verfluchen zombies magier
alles hexen alles die waren halt so ok
ich verhext jetzt stürzt danach nämlich
krassen tod aber du kannst das ticket
auch noch kosten und zwar für diese app
eine gruppe teenager zu einem tatort
also die haben zumindest etwas sehr
schlimmes in einem koffer gefunden
naja also back in den ländern so also
einfach etwas was kann da jetzt diese
app bewertung networking ist
wahrscheinlich ihr erster gehversuch so
als technik youtube bis dahin noch nicht
so viele reviews von verfluchter technik
gemacht insofern darf man uns zu asche
gegenüber sein aber wir es funktioniert
einfach nicht auf meinem handy
ich glaube ich habe mal was was was ist
wenn ich jetzt auch verfluchter apps
haben werden und es geht nicht toll
danke kleine pizza also leute mein
persönliches review von diesen
versuchten apps ist muss wirklich sagen
alle schrott 0 von zehn ich konnte
keinen einzigen geist damit beschwören
es ist wirklich komplett hängen
geblieben rebecca muss als technik
youtube jetzt noch einiges dazulernen
ihr kriegt jetzt hier darüber einfach
ich vorgeschlagen das video hier oben
könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren macht
das und
so nett und verfluche ich nicht mit
allen apps nicht mehr raus